joining me now is michael anton former
trump nsc official
and author of the stakes
michael um got a lot of news on this uh
and we'll get to that in a moment but
have you ever heard
donald trump utter one disparaging
comment
about our troops or our fallen heroes
no and i was with him for the first 14
months of the administration on
every foreign trip well i've had lots of
interaction with the military
uh to military bases overseas in the
united states
uh i never heard him say anything like
that one thing i did hear him say which
you just mentioned
in your opening i did hear him ask
really pointed questions to generals and
to senior officials
that they had trouble answering um you
know
on more than one occasion they were
taken aback i think they had gotten used
to getting rubber stamped
they had they were so unused to
answering these kinds of questions that
they
would get flustered and couldn't think
of anything and one point rather
humorously the president said
which i think they thought they were
going into a meeting where they would
just stick something in front of him and
he would sign it and that would be that
and he said all right you know and he
kept them very long and he asked them
lots and lots of questions and he said
okay the next time i see you you're
gonna have answers to all these right
because you don't have them now and i'm
not gonna do anything
until i hear more from you and there was
a
let's just say the mood around the table
was somewhat sullen as the meeting broke
up and they streamed out
and michael i want to get your reaction
to this breaking news tonight
a senior defense official telling fox
news that the pentagon
the president and pentagon will announce
tomorrow
that they're cutting u.s troop levels in
iraq by a
third from 5 200 to about 3 500 troops
now this announcement was apparently
planned
before the atlantic article dropped
and it's it's keeping with his promise
to bring our troops home
but could this have been an impetus
at least for pushing this atlantic hit
piece out
with zero on the record sources
it i i it could be i'm sure but i think
the meta
reason for the atlantic hit piece is
much more political it's to
um see what they can do to drive down
the president's popularity with the
military
uh having to do with the election i
think i hate to say it it also has to do
with
a lot of this kind of crazy coup talk
that the democrats
have been engaging in over the course of
the year including joe biden saying you
know the military won't let him stay
past january 20th the military will be
on my side
uh there's been a lot of this kind of
nutty talk that really
terribly tears at the military civilian
relations
in this country which is one of the
bedrocks of our government and
uh you know here the cynic in me is
thinking it had
more to do with that but you know you
could be right though since a move like
this any kind of true production
is in the week is in the works for
months it takes a long time
to get these policies readied and signed
off and in the meantime as
it's getting ready lots and lots of
people see it so there are a lot of
opportunities
for leaking and talking out of school as
these things work their way through the
process
now mike you've just written a book
called the stakes
and it really just the title captures
really
how so many of us feel about this
election
that it's all on the line not just the
presidency but the country
is on the line explain well
look fundamentally right now i think the
two big issues of this
election i mean every election has a lot
of issues the two biggest ones are
uh woke mobs sacking burning looting and
destroying american cities and the covid
lockdown that's punishing our economy
and it's very clear where biden is he's
for the mobs
and he's for the lockdown i mean it may
sound harsh to say that he's for the
mobs but he
can only go out there and condemn
violence very blandly
he can't call out core democratic
supporters antifa and blm and anybody
and he can't even criticize these
incredibly feckless mayors that won't
enforce the law
in their cities or governors that won't
enforce the law but in some cases take
to twitter or take to the airwaves
and egg them on um biden has also said a
couple times that you know if he gets in
in there as president and the experts
whoever they are
say to him well we need more lockdown he
says i'll shut the country down
donald trump is definitely on the other
side of both of those two issues he's
made that plane all along
he definitely made a plane uh at the
rally that
some parts of which i saw in north
carolina but then there are his core
issues that he ran on in 2016 where they
are diametric opposites biden and trump
trump wants more immigration restriction
he wants a wall
he wants to clean up the dumbest aspects
of our immigration policy and reform the
system so that
we're uh putting american workers first
he wants to redress our trade imbalances
get tougher with china biden's been in
the pocket of china for a long time
and his record the obama administration
as being some kind of china facilitator
and then finally war which you've
already talked about they couldn't be
more different there
yeah i mean we have a president who has
just
helped broker a historic peace deal
between the uae and israel i mean obama
blinked
and he got a nobel peace prize it's just
a joke
and this is historic and it's a
collective yawn from most in the media
but they're coming into town next week
and they're going to celebrate that he's
a peacemaker and he's
he's he's tough and you know people
don't like his tweets but
i'd much rather have a peacemaker who
tweets some rough stuff
than a warmonger who is you know huggy
kissy with all the
all the constituents all the time so
michael your book is
fabulous everyone should go out and get
it the stakes michael anton thanks so
much